there's 175 men on team gb
but 200 women
remember the name caroline dubois aged
11
she had to choose a boy's name just to
get inside a gym
i said my name was colin and i was there
for like about six months
i think there's nothing more that i like
doing than proving people wrong
you know people say you can't do this it
just makes me angry and it makes me want
to say okay
let me show you that again also watch
out on the boxing team for lauren price
from ponte pool
and lower stuffed mum-of-three charlie
davison
look out for the blue hair of sinead
macintosh from edinburgh
she's our first shot at a medal laura
muir and keely hodgkinson are middle
distance medal prospects
and dina asher smith goes for gold in
the 100 meters
200 meters and four by 100 relay
in equestrian charlotte dujardan goes
for her third consecutive gold
sotu helen glover in rowing and jay
jones in taekwondo
there's also track cyclist royalty laura
kenny
it makes me proud that i can sit amongst
some of the best female athletes
and be part of that movement that is
currently happening
and it's not even just as a female as a
mum as well
ready set
liam heath won gold last time and those
arms haven't lost their strength
every athlete knows that their
meticulous planning and training could
be disrupted at
any point through the olympics by a
covert alert
or a positive test that is the tightrope
of the tokyo games adam petey is hot
favorite again
andy murray is back and watch for max
whitlock in gymnastics
in triathlon johnny brownlee goes alone
his older brother alastair
hasn't qualified this time and then
there's sky
brown just 13 years old but in with a
genuine shot at a medal
as skateboarding makes its debut these
games will surprise us
covid may disrupt things but team gb is
here
and they are ready to chase down their
dreams